I was thinking about this the other day
I can't even envision my life without
her anymore
julianne hough and Brooks Laich have
split after nearly three years of
marriage the couple released a joint
statement on Friday quote we have
lovingly and carefully taken the time we
have needed to arrive at our decision to
separate the couple continued by saying
they share a lot of love and respect for
each other and asked for privacy as they
move forward life is just life and
relationships are relationships and
people can deem them whatever they want
to be but I think as long as you know
what it is nothing else matters
Brooks and Julianne split comes after
weeks of fan speculation especially as
the now-former couple chose to
quarantine separately amid the corona
virus pandemic a source told ET in April
that it came down to a preference in
scenery Julie Ann is an LA girl and
Brooks prefers the scenic nature of
Idaho adding that they've been working
on their marriage and being apart is not
easy both the former NHL pro and singer
actress have been active on social media
during lockdown in fact Julianne has
left several friendly comments on Brooks
posts including a playful one on a
shirtless pic there's just there's no
room for negativity rumors that the
pair's marriage was on the rocks sparked
in early 2020 Brooke shared this post on
Instagram writing in the caption that he
was excited to step into a new chapter
in February Brooks confessed on his
podcast that he doesn't feel quote 100%
fully expressed in his sexuality and
last year Julianne revealed in women's
health magazine that she told Brooks
she's quote not straight the good news
is I am an open book so ask away and
I'll tell you what I want to tell you
the former couple started dating in 2014
and tied the knot in July 2017 et sat
down with Julianne in October 2017 and
gushed all about newlywed life oh man it
is so amazing I you know and everybody
all my friends are like I think you're
like the most excited person to be
married
because I I truly like when people ask
me that question I'm so I just light up
and I'm so happy our day-to-day life is
similar but just the deep amount and
like sense of love that you have for
this person and just just feeling
totally one is so much more grand than I
ever imagined